voltage is one of the most important
quantities and ideas in electricity and
in this video we're going to develop a
intuitive feeling for what voltage means
but it has to do with potential energy
of electrical charges and that's what
we're going to cover here is we're not
going to do a derivation but we are
going to do a intuitive description of
what voltage means we're going to start
with an analogy to gravity gravity and
voltage are really similar ideas I'm
going to draw a mountain here here's
here's some mountainside with snow on it
and I'm going to put a mass here here's
a mass of some mass m and it was lifted
up to the top of the hill
somehow by a ski lift by a mountain
climber something like that and if I put
it on top of the Mount and I let it go
the potential energy that it has is
going to be dissipated as kinetic energy
and that mass is going to roll down the
hill to here and as it does it can do
some work it can do some it can hit some
trees let's draw a tree and it can run
into a tree and knock that tree around
it can hit a bear it can bounce off
rocks all kinds of things so that's a
mass rolling down a hill now if I draw
this is a way to think about voltage
think about voltage as being another
mountaintop and this time we'll put a
battery in here this is our battery this
is what a battery does for us it
actually builds our mountain the battery
actually delivers electrons to the top
of the hill so here's that here's an
electron coming out of the battery
terminal the negative battery terminal
and if I release this it is going to
roll down the hill
and eventually it's going to return to
the bottom side of the battery but the
same thing this is the image you have in
your head when we hook up a circuit
along the way I can put in different
circuit components like resistors or
capacitors or anything like that and I
can make this electron do work and bump
into things as it goes down so the
amount of voltage here is proportional
to the height of this mountain a high
voltage is a high mountain and a low
voltages of low mountain the electrons
are pushed out the top by the battery
roll down to the bottom doing work along
the way and this is where we do our
circuit design that's what we're doing
over here we buy batteries and we do our
circuit design and study over here so
this is this is a pretty good analogy
for thinking about voltage as you begin
to build your circuits see you next time